on toute relative une étude de l'insee
sur les enfants du divorce la proportion
de familles recomposées progresse
régulièrement un enfant sur dix est
aujourd'hui concerné alors quelles
conséquences sur leur équilibre
la question est désormais aborder sans
gêne et sans tabou c'est le dossier de
cette édition il est signé laetitia
legendre et daniel n'est pas facile au
début de partager sa chambre avec de
parfaits inconnus
il faut céder sa télé sa console de jeux
son plat préféré et mains de sa mère
quand leurs parents l'ont quittée
conjoint et maison pour fonder une
nouvelle famille ces adolescents sont
passés de 4 à 9 personnes
il a fallu s'entasser et faire taire les
jalousies il est pas des groupes la ceni
faire là c'est mon frère on n'est pas
dans deux maisons différentes
on est tous ensemble ce qu une famille
des deux côtés il recherchait une
famille qui n'avait pu donc à la limite
ça s'est passé en douceur ils ont ils
ont vu qu'ici c'était plus calme plus
posé que la famille se recomposer avec
terre mère et enfant sans semble cuit
quoi depuis sur les sept enfants quatre
ans déjà quitté le cocon familial plus
débrouillards plus indépendant à leur
majorité les enfants de familles
recomposées quittent souvent leur par an
plus tôt que les autres
à 20 ans contre 21 ans dans les familles
traditionnelles selon l'insee il
connaîtrait aussi plus de difficultés à
l'école surtout lors de la séparation
des parents ont compensé des problèmes
scolaires qui arrive est bon at elle
peut t'aider à telle fête est née
maintenant je m'en sors les problèmes
scolaires ça venait du fait que tes
parents se disputaient en grande partie
est ici alors de trouver quoi ah ben je
sortirai mais l'échec scolaire je crois
qu'il n'est pas du tout du à allah à la
séparation des parents il est plutôt due
aux conditions séparation les divorces
pénalise ainsi les scolarité des enfants
la durée de leurs études s'en trouverait
raccourcie d'un an le taux d'échec au
bac double dans les familles aisées
séparer aujourd'hui les divorcés
n'hésitent plus à refaire leur vie
depuis 1990 ce modèle de famille a
progressé de 10%
même si ce n'est pas facile tous les
jours qu'il faut apprendre à vivre à
neuf et que ça suppose certains
sacrifices
un truc qu'avant on supporte avec jean
pla de marque mais est ce qu'ils sont
contents alors plein fouet claquer des
doigts pour un morceau souvent les
familles recomposées sont plus fragiles
que les autres éclatent régulièrement
les bras m ce ne réalisent pas qu'ils
sont une exception
vous considérez comme ans comme egos et
si son arrivée chez moi ce sont mes
enfants mon titre que les miens promène
sur fragon pas de problème